marie-guite dufay fait son entrée dans
l'hémicycle ce matin et donne aussitôt
le ton l'a tellement de travail à faire
mais il faut rester cool oui pour faire
les choses
méthodiquement chaque chose en son temps
chaque jour et vous le voit et c'est le
prg le parti radical de gauche qui va
lui donner du boulot dans l'escalier
elle croit justement l'un des deux élus
prg
à ce moment là problème les deux élus
prg ne veulent pas voter du fait au
premier tour
la réunion du groupe ps au premier étage
est tendue ça se passe comment là et
bien ça se passe que on organise la
tendance
fonctionnement du groupe les commissions
les relations avec le prg relation avec
le père faisait alors ça se passe
comment là on n'en saura pas davantage
et à 14h30
arrive le moment tant attendu les 100
conseillers régionaux vote pour élire
leur président aucun candidat pour la
droite le front national présentes
sophie montel et le ps marie-guite dufay
au premier tour quoique marie-guite
dufay n'obtient que 49 voix la majorité
est à 51
il lui manque donc a priori les deux
voies du prg pour être élu c'est après
une suspension de séance
un deuxième tour est organisé les
socialistes semblent moins tendu il
compte lui voit ouf
cinquante-et-une marie-guite dufay
socialiste est donc élue c'est la
première présidente du tout nouveau
conseil régional de bourgogne franche
comté